ben 10 hilary citoyens at il pas un n'a
rien à [ __ ] de ce que je raconte
peut-être non mais citoyen actif tu
connais pas tiens le voile à regarder
cette monnaie
ce qu'il soit là actifs
et celle de la grande journée des
rebelles vaut mieux essayer
ok moi il m'a planté 3 l'apport du jour
là j'ai vu lui laissant le dur il m'a
dit alors c'était bien le dîner avec
jamel qui n'est pas venu et m'a dit mais
moi il n'est pas venu au mien de ce qui
m'a dit qu'il est inactif la promotion
d'angela le collectif rhumerie juliette
bientôt comment ça va citoyens actifs
ça va ça va aller voter un fou et tais
toi mon répondeur téléphonique lui il me
demande de me rappeler une en thaïlande
tu connais un peu sa casquette parce que
je te vois pas la sava d'accord je suis
pas allé chez le coiffeur
assez pour s'agisse la fusion était
collectif léché thibault alors jusqu'à
les faire jusqu'à la fin du mois de
décembre la faune allemand et après on
fait ça recommence en septembre prochain
jusqu'à décembre jusqu'à décembre que de
septembre me demande pas comment ça
fonctionne je suis pas au fait de tout
ça c'est vraiment là on aura je sais que
ça fonctionne comme ça d'ailleurs nous
lâche au dernier moment sur simple pour
ça que le truc c'est monter enfin
l'appel on a eu deux semaines on peut
pas appeler tous les médias et pour y
aller quoi je kiff kiff un peu qu'on a
une légitimité pour aller dire aux gens
un peu aussi à l'heure d'aujourd'hui
s'il vous plaît allez vous inscrire et
puis réagissez fédéraux nourrir ainsi de
suite
c'est que justement fut déjà la base un
trail de foi et d associer des as aux
aussi ensuite il faut absolument que
tout le monde prenne conscience qu'il
fallait chercher sa carte d'électeur
banlieue pas blanc banlieue arrêter de
créer des camps et nous nous expliquer
que ces gens là se comporte mal ces gens
là c'est nous ces gens là c'est vous
c'est toute la france se tirer une balle
dans le pied que que ghettoïser que de
sectoriser comme ça à la france est pas
possible comme ici on a vérité la
réconciliation
et ça on l'attend en afrique du sud en
afrique d'ici de péronne en français
c'est des gens qu'il va croiser rayon
voter les lois
voilà pour qu on positive l'action
coloniale si on va pas au fond de ce qui
s'est passé et de rotherm de de revenir
à la mémoire de ce qui s'est passé que
les gens parlent et se et ce qu'ils
soient déjà entendu et qu'on enregistre
les toutes les histoires à ce moment-là
ça changerait déjà dans la situation
dans les mentalités
question si on va pas dans les dents les
générations d'avant les générations qui
viennent à présent toujours mal mais
c'est un cancer façon la france on peut
enfin moi je le savais enfin j'ai
remarqué encore un peu plus dernièrement
quoi la france a un peu peur de regarder
son passé dans les yeux quand à partir
du moment où on a colonisé des gens ils
n'ont donné où on a toutes les valeurs
de démocratie tout ça on les a oubliés
quoi vous donner je pense que c'est tous
ces gens qui aujourd'hui sont un peu
désoeuvrés façon je pense que si on leur
explique qu'en fait c'est la france qui
nous a fait nous sommes français quoi il
ya une vraie histoire autour de ça déjà
je pense que ça m'arrivait une confusion
une course une conscience civique et
ainsi de suite
donc c'est un mouvement pour la vraie
liberté la vraie égalité et la vraie
fraternité c'est ça ça c'est sympa comme
slogan c'est bien comme on n'a pas envie
de penser que c'est utopique vraiment y
croire parce que moi je crois en mon
pays je pas possible soit possible pour
nous explique matin midi et soir qu'on
n'est pas les bienvenus c'est pas
possible de gens et de jeunes quoi
oublier que l'on a on a pas mal de
chance content d'être en france mais
aussi à plein de choses que je pense que
pour parler franchement d'envoyer des
gens s'inscrire et voter prochainement
c'est sûr qu'en ce moment
si les plus jeunes voyais pratique et ça
comme un automatisme je pense qu'à long
terme se passera peut-être je crois que
je me la faut voir sur le long terme
d'anti sûr et puis ça peut susciter des
vocations aussi sait très bien que j'ai
prise de conscience citoyenne à la
géniale même placé pour pouvoir dire ce
qui manque en banlieue que je sois là
point de vue social pratiques ou autre
c'est quand les premiers protagonistes
vers les gens qui y vivent quoi il ya
des gens qui vont pas voter parce que
d'après ils n'ont pas le poids mais le
poil voix ne s'est passé
on voit même qui n'ai jamais voté donc
qui n'ait jamais déclaré vainqueur le
vin je vais chercher ma carte voilà tous
rendez vous en faites en face de la
mairie de clichy sous bois balayer une
journée c'est le 20 décembre la terreur
voilà pour organiser une marche
enfin c'est le truc symbolique mais ça
va je me souviens décembre à la mairie
pour s'inscrire
ouais ouais voilà c'est ça prenait
conscience une voix égale une voix ouais
surtout ne vous garez pas agréé chez ce
jour là est ce que les citoyens qui
restent avec nous soit intervenu très
bien